in the middle of this White House
turmoil Republicans are also dealing
with a potential loss of a House seat in
a strong GOP district dancin or is a
former adviser to Republican House
Speaker Paul Ryan good morning good
morning
looks like the Democrat may have won in
that pennsylvania district yeah it's bad
sign bad sign
that something which they it's the
seventh special election since President
Trump has been elected or since since
he's been sworn in eight if you include
the Alabama race and in each of these
races even though only a couple of the
Democrat has won you see massive shift
vote means you know Democrats shifted
the vote 16 18 20 points on average and
the President himself went there took
him to campaign himself and it looks
like the race was tighter before he
showed up so what what what it's looking
like is the president is very good at
motivating the opposition it's not clear
that he's good at motivating his base in
these congressional races so it's
another sign that you know Republicans
are facing real headwinds heading into
November and this was an election that
took pace after the tax cut bill was
passed which was supposed to be by the
speaker Paul Ryan and others the great
thing that was gonna get Republicans to
turn out and help Republican candidates
which I actually think the the tax cap
must message could be effective but
there has to be consistently deployed I
mean what you have with this president
is he's so dominant in every single news
cycle he's omnipresent just look we've
been talked about the past few days
staff shake-up this one's in this one's
out chaos North Korea I mean let's talk
about that for a second do you think
people care it's so hard to me to wrap
my brain around a porn star and a
president in the same sentence do you
think voters care about that story I
mean it's it's it's so beyond anything
we've ever had to deal with there's
there's very little recent precedent for
it but it seems to me if it if it
supports an if it's in service of a
narrative of chaos yeah if it's in
service of a narrative of corruption
it's a problem okay in that chaos you're
talking about is a consistent message
for those Democratic voters in other
words that's what gets them motivated is
the President and they feel kind of an
impotent rage that there's nothing they
can do about it one way they can do
something is elect them right I keep
telling my Republican friends who are
running for office the the opposition's
motivation and their energy is not
conditions base
it's not like if the they say the
economy's crankin what's doing great and
there's no national security Christ
crisis the world is basically stable
like we have a good story to tell but
the opposition is not their fears and
their and their anger is not calmed by
conditions it's all focused on one man
the revulsion against the president so
as long as he's in the frame they're
gonna turn out in huge numbers he says
that he likes working in chaos he says
that people are lined up for these
positions at the White House a do you
think that's true because I wonder what
it's like to work in a place where they
say dancing or your job is online
John Dickerson or O'Donnell where you
get up in the morning and your name is
in the headlines as possibly not having
a job by the end of the day who wants a
job like that it's uh it's very
difficult look there to me they're like
three profiles of people who go to serve
the president yes one of the loyalists
people who've been with the president
forever hope Hicks was like that too are
the sort of process people the people
who just want to serve the office they
feel like it's a public it's a role of
public service to come in in and out of
these administrations you know Jim
mattis he probably fits in that profile
john kelly and then there are the
ideologues and I don't say that
pejoratively people care about a set of
ideas and are there to like in advance
an agenda and the problem is if you look
at all three of those categories they're
all going normally a president can hang
on to the ideologues but the loyalists
make it to more light so the loyalists
want to hang around but the ideologues
don't see their agenda seen through here
you see everybody not tell us what
you're hearing about what changes are
gonna happen and who might replace
general Keller if he's Kelly appease
Houston I think actually Kelly's gonna
be around for a while
I mean people I've spoke to who spoke
from the president a lot of people speak
to people who speak to the president but
but there is a sense that he has been
frustrated with him but he is an anchor
there and he is solid so I think he'll
be there for a while I worry about
general McMaster I think it's talented I
think he could very very easily wind up
in Seoul Korea taking over US forces
there if if general Vince Brooks steps
down which it sounds like he is so I
would look out for McMaster as possibly
the next one to go okay all right thank
you dancing or